foreign
I am a bit late
sorry about that we had some technical
issues
that are now fixed
I hope
hello
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome
wait hold on let me check this real
quick real quick
hola
sorry about your issue it was annoying
but we are now good
hopefully
oh chat is on the screen and very large
holy okay
whoa
uh we're gonna tone that down a little
bit
that look okay
that seems fine
maybe a little bigger
hello everybody
bum hello Glenn
nuke Max I romance Schmicks
Nicola
vintage Cameron
dong Leo
hello everyone
yeah I did watch the Call of Duty event
that looks pretty cool
it do look pretty cool
ain't gonna lie
it looks like the best Call of Duty I've
seen in a little bit
I don't know where to go
I keep forgetting I have no sound in my
character also I I don't like where are
we gonna find
like random
uh
uh great runes
I guess we should go here and see if we
can actually like beat the
couple of
gargoyles in the classroom
that's some random drip it do fit it do
fit
we're beating the randomizer we're gonna
go as far as we possibly can
I love Call of Duty dude
I am a Call of Duty
big Call of Duty guy
I did not like Vanguard
holy crap I hate birds
Birds
I don't think I can use Rock sling yet I
actually can't
this damn bird
all right let's do our best we'll just
see how we're looking here
wag
pieces
I got stuck on a table man
you think this guy will give me room of
any kind
of
kinda
you gonna walk into that of course not
that hit me huh
I don't know about this one guys
considering we have to be two of them
foreign
I have been enjoying the randomizer
though it the randomizer makes the game
uh feel new
like every every corner I go around
every room I go into I don't know what
to expect which gives me the exact same
feeling of I had when I first played the
game
which is fun
okay I might try that again
foreign whoops did not mean to do that
okay
what does a randomizer do I mean did you
not see the two gargoyles in that room
and the bird right here and the dog to
my right and the crow I'm about to go in
a crow in this room
he randomizes the items in the enemies
in a
non-sarcastic answer
well
okay
okay
oh no I really just wanted the runes
there we go
not that it's gonna matter clearly
clearly
this is gonna suck huh
foreign
that hurt a lot
whoa
not the move I thought he was gonna do
not the move not the move
you come back over here please
this isn't awful like I feel like I
could get used to this somehow
and like figure out the moveset
tiny ass room
you know
so the other one should come out pretty
soon
I don't have FP
there it is
ow
stay over there
oh
dude
wow
dude having these poison guys in this
tiny room isn't possible
if I can get one down I feel like I can
kill the other one
I can't even yeah wow okay
that's true Leo I could check that out
as well
no summons I mean I haven't found
upgrades for it
I I'm gonna go ahead and say that's
impossible that seems impossible right
now I just need more damage
so where else could we go we'd be redone
that was Reichard out here
oh my game froze never mind we're good
did I um I haven't explored in here yet
hmm
site
um could I go well I can't get abducted
to go
wait didn't somebody last time we did
this my game is glitching didn't
somebody last time we did this say that
all I have to do down here is die
and it will still take me to volcano
Manor
dude why is my game
pooping out
hello
get get out of here you little dumb frog
it didn't die
where is it
all I have to do is die and it'll work
okay cool
oh now it's dead
it's over here real quick
let's give it a little check
you don't know like we could literally
find a great room down here
do crystal darts um if they do I don't
have them
because we can't like grab the ones that
we want you know what I'm saying
because nothing's in the right spot
okay there's an item
give me give me give me
poison darts that's something
Racers is not something
I wonder if I can still craft normally
probably
I haven't touched crafting in this game
yet so I wouldn't even know how to do it
too
yeah I thought you had to get swallowed
by a machine but enough people in chat
have said like all you have to do down
here is die
which is interesting
um oh there's the Frog
okay I've never died in one of these
things but we're about to
nice
oh you missed
good try though
come on you can do it
you don't have to okay
good good
it just goes side to sides
things actually kind of cute
all right
you guys are smart
what would I do without you
die in obscurity
okay I think we can still live from here
excellent excellent
what are you doing
excuse me
not be a popular Channel I mean if I
didn't have viewers I think that would
be the case
what is that
that is an importante item
oh oh God oh God
bruh
hey blue eyed how are you how are you
I'm dead it's over we died
I won't believe any other outcome but
death here
there's just absolutely no way we live
through this
malachette's Black Blade
holy [ __ ]
leave me alone
okay at least we got it
we got maleket's Black Blade
is that big is that big boys
let's see so we got death poker plus two
I'm gonna take this off for now
because we don't have the int
the end
sorry I'm really hyper today if you
couldn't tell I'm sorry it's gonna be
really annoying okay well death smoker
is clearly better right now but
we should keep all these weapons
the the hard part is like
upgrading options are limited because we
don't know exactly where to go to get
them
why the hell did that kill me
why
that makes no sense bro
I think I would fat roll with that
I think death smoker is actually going
to be better than that in the long run
what the f what the where did you come
from bro
stop it
stop this madness
what's happening
why is this killing me now I don't think
I went to the right spot
happy Friday
as I'm pissing myself off playing
randomizer on a Friday huh hopefully
it's fun to watch
hi Trey how are you sir
why did that bird just instant aggro
okay I think I have to I've been
dropping there and I need to drop here
I was incorrect with that incorrect
incorrect wrong
bad
two hours left of work then weekend time
let's freaking go bro
it's a great day it is a great day
it is an excellent day
dude why is this bird just on me
sometimes bro
like dog
bird
are you scaled can I just murder you
right here nope
nope
I'm scared this will kill me right yep
it's over
it's over
okay
this game makes no sense bird
why why
shut up godric
yes handgun thanks for becoming a
tarnished
oh welcome my dude good to have you
appreciate it very much welcome welcome
welcome
you joined for this emote it's probably
the best emote on YouTube just saying
this this bird is Bad News Bears bro
I really need this bird not here
I can't kill it it's too strong
is fall damage randomized
yes
no I have no idea
but handgun thank you very much
you're the man
hello
Alexander
son of [ __ ]
done a [ __ ]
oh I have a question for you guys do you
guys play Elden ring still
this is not the right spot I don't care
let's [ __ ] go boy
yeah
it died
and it gave me a bunch of runes let's go
foreign
[Music]
all right we can't die yet
yes
uh I do but I play with a friend this
time around nice nice I like that
still going strong you gain plus four
play it less but still do I mean
technically same
all right what we got here
wow the worst item in the game like the
biggest cuck item in the entire game is
what I got right there excellent
play bloodborne right now no
no
I'll do whatever I want
no
maybe tomorrow I want to finish this
it's annoying to set up a PS5 and a PC
Guild suits over here
it's the only game I play on PS4 I still
play still my original playthrough
though under leveled as a 77 at Castle
Soul yeah that's definitely on your
level
I'd say you want to be like level 90
before you get to Castle soul
and then Melania like if you're going to
the hay League tree hopefully you know
about that and I'm not destroying
I'm sure you know about Melania at this
point
um
probably like level 120 Maybe
I think that's good advice
at least level 100
finishing Alden ring inspired me to
platinum the rest of my from soft game
so I'm burnt out damn
that sounds fun though
oh you're playing bloodborne right now
dude you guys gotta remember something
I'm dyslexic
so sometimes when you like put things in
chat I'm just comp I read it completely
wrong
so I'm my bad
my bad
and you think I'm a streamer and that
happens right okay who we got in here
what do you guys think
please be something easy
please be something easy bro
please don't be Melania
is anything gonna oh
are you
are you kidding me
what
in tarnation
oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no
bro I have his move set so down though
so down bad
I can't leave
is the bird back please let the bird be
insta dead
I have to make this run every time
why does this game hate me no
no
stay
yeah I think radagon's one of the best
bosses in the game
I love radagon however did you guys see
the damage I was doing
with a plus two deaths poker
it wasn't great
hey jellyfish like why couldn't it been
any
anything other than radagon
okay you guys are saying there I
remember we had this argument last time
you guys are saying there's a side of
Grace over there right
behind that door
that you can't get in from this
direction
we've had this argument
are you talking about that one
people got very upset last time we
talked about this
like yes you can Jake
yes you can
Arie
I think we had to ban somebody because
they were so mean about it no no you're
good you're good you're good you're not
even close to what that person was doing
okay you want to see this you want to
see this right here look at that
oh
God
is there a sight of Grace in that
building just a question
I did go Super Saiyan
I'm really hyper today guys it's it's
all out there
there is where
okay let's go find it
because I do not remember
that would help us a lot
golden vow extra damage extra damage
excellent
what is something big walking around
here bro
there's something very large is a round
that I don't think is supposed to be
around
you know what I'm saying
we're gonna leave that thing over there
I respected Jake it's the weekend also
are you streaming more often now that's
my plan
to stream a lot
I would say I'm a better streamer than I
am like video maker
I definitely have more experience
streaming that's for sure
okay I'm just kind of looking around
right now but there could be freaking
anything in here oh my God
why is my game stuttering dude stop it
bro
are we like for real with this like uh
okay
can I sneaky sneak
nope
I got a helmet I got a helmet I got a
helmet I got a helmet I got a helmet
golf stream win
uh when I have enough subscribers to
where the algorithm won't [ __ ] me for
making anything else how about that
that was a burp by the way I burped
Sauber four let's go
that's big huge do I have a somber three
no I need a three okay we need a three
that's what we're looking for next
that was big value big money
Big Value big money
I'm over this okay
foreign
you know
lol imagine dying to your own thing
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa chill
bro
you better give me a good item because
this is with dick
feet me
no item cool
hey guys remember when we kill Moog
Moog the grafted and he get
okay I'm over this
remember we killed Moog the grafted and
he gave us 15K
15K runes
and uh
the both sides of the dectus medallion
whoa let's go we need a three though
dude
ghost Flame's not black flame oh yeah
why do they look so similar though why
do they look so similar
okay actually I'm gonna kill these guys
because I don't know if they're gonna
give me anything
yeah I've been hearing a lot that
there's a difference I didn't know there
was a difference in the flame like
really
it doesn't seem like it bro
I need to kill everything
just have a chance of getting a good
drop
okay these guys aren't too bad it's
really dark in here
oh titties oh titties
you're dead
you're dead
I hate these things somber seven we're
getting all the sombers bro
keep hitting boys
I'm dead it's over there's also a wolf
in here wrong flask
dude
die
thank you stop
get some help
get some help
yeah
nope no hug please no hug no hug
guy
LOL frog
okay a lot of these guys are taking a
ridiculous amount of hits right now
oh my God there is one in here boys
holy [ __ ] we banned a guy because we
didn't believe him
last week
oh no
oh no
well
rip that guy
banning's bad okay
Hey listen if you're mean about it
I think you get banned regardless
you know what I'm saying
because you know what I I remember him
being specifically like
he'd go like dude are you [ __ ] dumb
you stupid idiot there's a bonfire in
there and he like would say bonfire not
even Grace
be like well I don't remember one can
you point out where and he would go
across the bridge obviously
duh
if he were dislike nice about it he'd
probably still be here
that was rude of them dude people have
been quite rude online lately
very rude
okay excellent runarc we'll take it
Banning is my Kink you should be a
moderator then
whoo
let's go this way
ow ow please stop
I forget where I am apparently
online and in person too dude I woke up
to a comment today like I got on the
YouTube Studio first comment I saw
was you had all the potential to be a
big YouTuber so sad
and I'm like dude we're growing every
day like what the [ __ ] you talking about
Jesus
I looked them up zero subscribers zero
videos
well
interesting
interesting
guy had a little moment
this is very bad
please stop
why am I doing nothing to him
where's the scaling
is he weak to ghost flame
whoops
oh dude not fair at all
foreign
there's something
leave me alone
you didn't leave me alone like I said
maybe he meant big as in fat
like he wanted me to be a fat YouTuber
they're jealous hello oh 100 I didn't
take like any offense to it obviously
because it's just some random person
uh but
I did read it I'm like what the [ __ ]
where are you even getting that from you
know
and then you know you just disregard it
from your brain
well you're Leo weirdo
this is my last randomizer stream yeah
I'm gonna try and get as far as I can
with it
before we uh switch
oh you little imp
um we need to go back to old school if
you have nothing nice to say don't say
it
can you imagine if people on the
internet did that
I think the world would be a better
place
he's strong against frostbite man that
sucks
is there any lore reason why that's the
case because he's got holy like I would
imagine he's got holy stuff right
[Music]
foreign I do like to think I'm pretty
good against his normal move set
although it can Bop you pretty quick
nice suit
nice suit
he's technically dead radagon yes I
believe so
he's just like a puppet
so is America
that's what I get out of it at least
owie
[ __ ]
he's shirtless so clear Frost weakness
you're right you're right
does he have a stage too yes his stage
two is
uh
going Non-Stop
all over you
okay so there's another area that I
don't think we can get into
that I don't think we could progress
at all what do you guys think you know
what we should do is go to the Mist wood
that might be our next best call or we
could go to Knox Stella
hmm hmm
hmm
hmm
let's see let's see let's see because
that's not gonna happen that's a
ridiculously hard
if I could get a plus three
somber we could upgrade
let's see if we got a three we could
upgrade one two three
three times and if we got a six
five times
should that be our next mod
what are you sell selling young a
pregnant
I do want to do a playthrough where
everyone is Rick I just think that would
be hilarious to do for like one day
it's just soldier of godric
everyone is Soldier of godric scaled
let me see what's in here real quick
and give this a little Bop
stop
the car
nice we got the animation excellent
wow that was so worth it to get some
[ __ ] gloves bro
I love gloves gloves are awesome
it's so helpful in my Endeavors
currently
wow
I love that let's see what's up here
first
man I'm really [ __ ] hyper
I'm sorry
no we can't access Landell or this you
mean the capital city
we don't have any great runes even
though we've killed two great two
demigods they don't give us great roots
hi Buddha how are you
radagon is a misbegotten warrior The
Crucible
hmm
dude why is there always
this guy
wait we already did this didn't we we
did we did we did we did we did we did
we did we did
we did we did we did we did we did
item
what
the thing about me being hyper though is
it means I'm gonna get tired quicker
I'm literally a [ __ ] baby
like a child
gets all hyper and then needs his nappy
okay
I think most people are low-key like
that though
it's Hal
foreign
all yourself Trey or do you prefer
people to call you Hal now
what am I hearing
I'm scared my game froze
Frozen
well now I gotta check what's in here
that's usually where the bear is right
no bear
I'm Hal at work Trey everywhere else got
it
nomadic Warriors cookbook
we'll take it why is my game doing that
I hate it
is our boy still here
oh
nope
I doubt blyde's appearance would change
at all
my game is really struggling today I
don't understand why this is the case do
you guys want to go to through the
through the elevator down to nocron or
do you want to go to Knox Stella
I think Knox Stella might be like more
let's see what the mimic tier boss is
right
that'd probably be because we'd have to
light a bunch of fires to see the boss
in nocron yeah
yeah let's do this for now
we just need to level up and find
sombrers
because we are in extremely low level
like I still can't believe we beat Moog
at this level
it's kind of nuts
very Epic
just completed downloading Sakira gonna
start it now rage quit the game twice
um sakiro is the hardest soft from
software game for for sure
the hardest of all of these games
it is a steep learning curve how many
sevens do I [ __ ] have
I have four somber sevens bruh
four
cut me a break
oh isn't that a talisman
raises attack power with lower equipment
load
[Music]
nice
should I be wearing this
increases damage taken
7777
[Music]
I don't want to talk about it
think about skiro though there's no
multiplayer so every accomplishment was
100 you it makes bosses a [ __ ]
so rewarding to beat
I agree
I sakiro
I think has the best combat of any of
these games
oh no I'm on the wrong level
yeah I clearly slipped right guys
I clearly slipped
and has nothing to do with skill
at all
couldn't be a skill issue
oh that's what I saw
a gargoyle and a dragon right next to
each other excellent
no you you actually gotta get good at
sakuro or you're gonna get effed
you're gonna get absolutely bonked if
you don't get good
uh I did odd Lang I did the for the last
two videos that I've done which was uh
about the Sony state of play
and the
like
little clip from the mo randomizer
YouTube did not like those videos at all
and they were like [ __ ] you
um don't make content like this ever
again I was like all right bet sorry
my bad
oh Cron
there any items up here
I don't think so
listen guys I am at the mercy of the
algorithm okay
and so is every Creator you know of
no no no it's not communism it's just
how it works
unfortunately
free so free
oh okay I thought it was a dog
no
power okay
that answer's dead
did the clip get demonetized no no it
didn't get demonetized it was just app
shown to absolutely nobody
the algorithm said please no
and so did 90 of people who saw the
video
like I like I said earlier
people are being quite mean on the
internet lately
so I'll just not do that
what are you cool
[Music]
okay we have it
no I'm sure you guys liked it
if you did like it I appreciate you
nice
I thought it was a cool event too
I want to knock you off the ledge
yeah
you're done
you're done
doggy stop
I'm dead I think
I was wondering what was shooting at me
this little hoe in the corner
like
that
yeah I took it down so my panel doesn't
get F by the algorithm again
I'm just wondering your way to the city
around seven minutes ago that is okay we
are not gonna get every item
I don't think it hurts to have the video
still up I believe it does
it's okay so here's how YouTube works
I am not in a position right now to
experiment with anything
if if I change what I'm doing right now
YouTube will just be like okay this guy
is not consistent at what he does and
we're just gonna take him down like not
take me down it's like uh what do they
call it
uh Shadow Banning
I think is what people know it as they
will stop recommending my videos to
people
um it'll just get infinitely less views
uh so
to combat that you just go with what the
algorithm wants you to do and it's like
you go with what they put you in to do
in the first place
if I had
a million Subs there's a potential that
I could experiment because there's just
so many people there that can change the
algorithm for me
but
even with like what are we at
93 almost 94 000. it's not enough to
where there's not enough people who
actually
watch
the content I'd say there's like a few
thousand like four to five thousand
people who will watch anything I put out
but then YouTube sees that as why is the
sky have 4 000 views instead of a
hundred thousand views like he usually
does the algorithm takes that and they
just they think you're not making good
enough content and they'll just take you
out of the algorithm
unfortunately that's how it works I
don't want that to be the case
black knife print what is that
but that is how it do work
and I trust me I would love to diversify
my content
I would love it
it's a quest item which Quest
I don't remember
oh God not one of you I do not like
these enemies
please stop hitting me mommy please stop
hitting me Mommy
is that Ronnie's
think so
I didn't have stamina shoot
damn you hit really hard
excellent
oh it's Roger that's right thank you
[Music]
um
do I see a pogger's item over here
I do
whoa
I got plastic Deuce ax's sword
cool
ing here please don't kill
this flower this flower
he's still shooting at me man
the flower way over there
yeah that's good to hear Nick I'm glad a
ton of big creators try and justify how
they got success but I like moist
criticals admittance to
admit it's that too much of it is luck
based it's a
it is a thousand percent luck
on getting out there for people to watch
yeah I just got [ __ ] flowered bro
absolutely flowered on
but oh no it's a bird
anything but a bird
you guys ask me any questions you want
on YouTube I will answer it
it's hard as [ __ ]
leave me alone bird
all right is it
can the mimic tear be a different boss
hmm
oh God
ruin Arc not worth not worth
not worth
yes there are so many content creators
out there who do not get the views that
they should
and there are content creators out there
that get a ton of views for very
basic
content
no
no
I disagree
I disagree with this
what's he gonna do when he rolls man
guaranteed hit me
what
where's your plate
bruh
what were we talking about you should be
getting more views now I think that
I wish I had more people in my live
streams
we actually have a good amount
every time we go live we have a good
amount of people here
not compared to like people who have
tens of thousands of people in their
chat but
you think he could like roll out of the
arena and die
it feels like nothing scales properly
Leo it says it does but I'm getting uh
Vibes that it does not
no no no no no no no
unfair attack right off the rip
this man just [ __ ] rolled he just
rolled
foreign
excellent this is good we like this guys
we like this
no no no take take your plate
five dollars to the fire giant he
deserved it
where is there a stake America okay
give this five dollars to the fire giant
he deserved it you got it man
thank you for the five dollars
I will give it to him as he [ __ ] slaps
me I didn't realize I already did one of
these
um this is gonna be weird we're gonna
have to get used to this
you know it's almost like having radagon
in a tiny Arena
you know
very interesting
thank you handgun
try dodging thank you Johnny L
can we get some L's in the chat for
Johnny
get some L's in there for this guy what
amazing advice I appreciate that
really living up to your name
okay I'm trying to dodge the foot when I
need to dodge the plate
it's so hard to tell what he's doing
I can't see
your foot's up on a Ledge dude
that's cool
[Music]
yeah get your ass down here
hope he's rolling
no no
stop it
fall off
he's actually almost falling out of the
map
this is going well
yes he's being facetious
I can also make fun of Bunker being
facetious
this this is dumb
he's gonna fall he's legit gonna fall
never mind
never mind
never mind
yeah am I gonna get phase two here
we got real lucky right there guys
foreign
this is so weird
is that a ball
oh no
scuffed
I hate you
this is like the worst Arena I think he
could be in
at least it has some height to it right
I can't see
this is actually going better than it
seems
[ __ ]
I am incredibly focused right now
foreign
I [ __ ] up
okay we just gotta go for hits
no way
imagine I die right there
let's go
wow a ghost glove wart Pickers Bell one
that's amazing so worth the fight wow
gosh that's great
that's so good
I love that for me
sarcasm
man
that's great okay I'll stop
that turned out to not be that hard
yes this is the last day
you earned a sense of joy and
accomplishment
all right
you're right I do
oh that's true it's not even the same
items right let's go and see what these
actually are
okay
this [ __ ] door to Gideon isn't even
open yet
okay offer Bell bearing
thank you
Melbourne's shop
wait what was it
it was the
it was like ghost glove wart Bell
bearing right
okay we have to go to each individual
shop by the way
anyone see a somber 3 no
um
nope
somber five
no this is just the last day I'm gonna
do it
[Music]
poor collie spell bearing
nothing of immense interest there
we can get another sacred tear we can
get another Talisman pouch
that's pretty cool
okay
um oh oh oh eight nine
two nine slots and an eight
I love that for us and it's extremely
expensive
you're having an issue with your videos
right now what is that
are you way behind
is this guy way behind you think like
what we were talking about before
[Music]
quit praying
[Music]
a lot of these we can sell
it's in the normal shot menu I didn't
see anything in there
fortunately let's go check again
let let us go
so just in here
uh uh yeah this is like most of the
stuff I remember from before
we're kind of getting effed right now
aren't we
do I have like better armor options
Royal Knight armor
wow I look so dumb
man
wow
yikes okay
let's go back to this
no armor upgrading
imagine if you could upgrade torrent how
cool that would be okay there's like
nothing here
let's go back down under
and see what else we can do
first off I can read all of your
messages
have been
you might be slightly behind
oh
oh [ __ ] dick oh no
I just wanted to see what that thing
would give me man
I turned a little bit too hard
I know that's the point ooh you're
giving me really bad vibes really bad
like right there I don't like you now
I don't I don't like you right now
oof okay here I am
not distracted
bye bye hey
oh okay I'll take it
sorry I mean you kind of did it on
purpose
which makes you really like kind of suss
man
super duper sus
one death one push-up
nice
you're gonna get jacked
dead bird
super duper sus
stone sword key nice nice very nice very
good very good very good very good
let's see what we get when we do these
didn't know scarabs have dragon hearts
well now you do
clearly they have dragon hearts my man
thanks Garrett
I think uh
uh what's gonna replace the wolf over
here
I know that I know I just like telling
people
the wrong information
when you know they don't know what a
randomizer is
foreign
maybe I'm a little weird for that
maybe I'm sus
could be
I could be very sus
excellent excellent
nice I got some string
big value
massive value
oh I would not imagine you'd get
free
here we go pop
lean rot gauntlets we'll take it
uh no no pork
it is completely random
We Got The dectus Medallion from killing
Moog
we did get both halves of it though
which I would I yeah that's pretty big
value it's okay
it's like not bad
it's not the worst I've ever heard
eat let's see what we got going on in
here
ew I'm scared
like anything but a lobster bro
I'm dead it's over
oh
I thought it glitched
you're bad
dude
why is the lobster so strong
foreign
tell fear Productions that he's like 10
minutes 15 minutes behind and he's not
live
you died
I sure did
should I even go see what that item is
behind the lobster
it's probably not worth
the last one it's over here right yeah
yeah I could get more string that's true
I love string
okay we got that open I'm just gonna
book it for it if we die we die
I think my least favorite is the singing
pterodactyls
they're singing pterodactyls you mean
the bats
it could be a great Rune or
it could be more string
I mean what would you rather have right
did I read that wrong pets what are what
is that
I read pterodactyls pterodactyls
pterodactyls never mind
some smart word I don't know
yeet
there we go okay okay okay okay okay
okay
okay come on let's go
my frames
wow
I love that for us
heal
Serpentine
okay
we are alive and well
thank you gasly
is that a good uh here
it's probably all right I haven't I
don't even have wondrous physic do I
oh
I know we all wanted string
would have been nice
okay let's go see what this boss is
Living Like Larry
you guys ever met someone who said they
never watched SpongeBob and you just
immediately don't trust them
yep it's gonna be the Eldon Beast
dude I love this because I have no idea
what could be here
I have met people who have not watched
SpongeBob
Ronaldo
where the [ __ ] are you shooting girl
Regal Renault spirit this kind of fits
does this kind of fit a bit yeah this is
cool
oh I like this
I like this this is cool
stop spamming though
[Music]
oh
nice
burn woman
[Music]
burn
foreign
yeah the the lighting does match her
attacks it's really cool I like this
[Music]
foreign
I have no stamina
I'm dead
[Music]
that could have killed me
oh you're insane
I'm dead it's over
foreign
that's really cool
I do like no damage man
it's like any of these bosses
no we we faced her creepy her creepy
children face
at the Storm Castle Bridge
stormvale Bridge not Storm Castle
yeah she's very uh I noticed they they
made her more spammy
they did the same thing with Gideon
like she she just goes off on you man
how about I do that like a hundred times
okay maybe we don't do that
uh so as old rinologist sitting around
somewhere just waiting to get thrashed
without phase two no
I think they're two completely different
things like there's Ronaldo who
goes up in the bubble and then sits
and sits uh like she'll respect you and
stuff and then there's this Ronaldo
who's like not even real
it's like Ronnie's manifestation of when
Ronaldo was extremely strong and not out
of her [ __ ] mind
lore wise does that make sense
is the Ronaldo we respect with is nuts
absolutely nuts
they just locked her in a library
nice nice nice
get owned
oh I'm almost the best
this is risk
they got her though
I had to dodge the second one
nope not what I wanted to do man she
does so much damage
foreign
I have not did I fight Gideon yet I
don't think so have I
books are evil I always forget Ronnie
disses you and is making the illusion
you fight teleside and the game just
moves on from it yeah I mean I hope they
do a little bit of DLC
with ranala because I think there's so
much more to her story than anybody
actually cares about
it's kind of weird like she got
her story is extremely sad
and I think she got used
and then it broke her heart
I think she got used on purpose
by America it was radagon
but then radagon like actually fell in
love with her
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
not really worth it is it
no
I should have died
that could have killed me
owie
okay honey
oh hi Meg
how's work going
that's my sister
I was distracted
damn it
[Music]
huh
no it's not your fault it's mine I'm bad
my sister didn't kill me I'm bad at the
game
nope nope not your fault not your fault
not your fault
yep Jake bad MK that's the answer
do you guys think Ronnie looks after her
I mean she
has that spell for her so it makes sense
that she does you know
trying to sorta
oh oh oh oh no and I used the wrong
thing this is bad
okay my character did not roll
[Music]
yeah your chat was extremely far behind
fear
like 20 30 minutes almost
we can kill her though
we can kill her
love you too have a great day at work
no no no no no we'll kill her in like
one or two more tries
this is fine
do we even get a lot of runes for this
oh
the burping started
[Music]
close
thank you
mm-hmm
that's a big old yeppers right there
[Laughter]
no I was in such a good flow
oh [ __ ] yo
[Music]
okay that dog hits for a significant
amount
dude
unfair unfair
unfair I say unfair
life ain't Fair [ __ ]
nobody cares
hey this music in this fight matches so
well it's really cool
can we uh stop spamming potentially
I think there's a potential that that
could stop
get out of here with that [ __ ]
[Music]
what did I say boys one or two more
tries how about one more try how about
one more try dude and we got
let's go
whoa
totally worth
great room number one
let's go
whoa
now I'm gonna go to his uh Divine Tower
finally got a great rune
watch it not turn into the great Rune at
the Divine Tower can you imagine
okay where is it
we're kind of like right under it
wait
it's over here
she was cheating with radon ranala no
that's her son
you mean radagon
would call it cheating
up let me spend the Rooney voice
yeah we'll check out the bottom of the
tower as well of course of course
oh God ew I mean it is a it is a
um George RR Martin game so
I don't even know what's a level anymore
like let's look at our items and see
what we're freaking going for here
uh
yeah that's poker with scales with
Stacks strength decks in int kinda I
want to use Rock sling which I think
will be helpful which is
that's for in as well
which is 18 intelligence which I can use
and I wield this uh staff we got
which I need 48 intelligence for
[ __ ]
Let's uh let's level that
yep America and radagon aren't just
siblings they're the same organ they're
the same person he went so hard with
incest that they became one bean
I should just make like a parody
lore video of this entire game and just
like make fun of the game like that
be hilarious
here's a little pot boy
what up jar Barn
you're really strong
now you're not
what an epic way to die
yeah it's self-assessed
the whole story is about a super
dysfunctional weirdly incestuous family
yup sure is
it sure is isn't that great
I just need to like one day when I'm
feeling like Mega sarcastic just make a
video like that
wow
wow
wow wow
that ant just splooged all over me and I
died
what Souls game has the most confusing
lore for you
uh Elden ring by a [ __ ] mile
by a an absolute Landslide Elden ring
stop it
ant splooge has a ring to it
I guess so
I just really want DLC
I don't care what it is
oh that didn't that didn't go
over I'm obviously quite scared
[ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] ass ant
[ __ ] ass aunt
silly ant
Melania Michelob literally resulted of
self-sess explains their curses I guess
just birth defects
um to my understanding
or
there's theories on this that either
Melania was born
with the Scarlet rot as an Affliction
from incest
or
um they put the god of rot within her
to suppress it and then she uh doesn't
suppress it
okay let's go see what's going on in
here
and I have guard in the side of the gate
oh I should go upstairs first I should
not go down here yet
what's so confusing you just get the
Eldon string to mend the thingamajig
right exactly
you're exactly right
wait is this even gonna be open up here
because I haven't technically killed
redone yet
I just thought of that
okay so we have his great room so that's
what opens it got it
thank you Garrett
whoop
if not for your vids I probably wouldn't
have ran through plus five full rounds
of Elden ring really
I helped you with playthroughs
I didn't think this would be open either
Barney eldering DS2 most original item
descriptions pre-scholar were written in
hypothetical
questions
I mean isn't that a theory with
um
with this game's item descriptions is
that they're like
uh written by somebody who doesn't
really know everything
there it is
I hope we still get the great Rune when
I press the button
excellent
whoa let's go
you use the Elden string to forge the
elden's sweater
I like your lore better than the main
lore
elokey made the game fun
with my lore videos I made it fun
that's good
that's very good to hear
bum
[Music]
oh wait wait wait we have six run arcs
let's hit it
oh yeah
it went up a little
okay these guys are weird
who do an absurd amount of damage
bye bye
nope can't even hurt these guys
I'm out of here I'm out of here
I struggle to Traverse this
every time
okay okay I need help here can I roll
into that or do I have to do a little
jump
I've been down here in a while
I've been watching this stream from work
and just have to say [ __ ] has been
extremely enjoyable and entertaining
cheers hey that's great to hear man
just step with a purpose got it
great advice Ryan let's go Ryan
I think that's the proper way to do it
thank you
close one boys okay
what we got here little crabby boy
we got a little crab
can't possibly die to a tiny little crab
okay excellent
what a replacement
I played this game too many times I mean
I have over 500 hours now and I feel
like I know nothing again
like I've I've spent all my time in the
last six months trying to understand
this game and I feel like I don't know
anything
anybody else feel that way
oh little cutie
except you have the same health bar
foreign
see if this guy drops anything
go
smoldering butterfly gold tinge
instrument
nice guys we got some literal [ __ ] let's
go
I love that for us
we got some extra mint
which is poop
I love that
is there any lore reason why we live
from that
I've learned America's radagon yeah I we
know that
do we know how
like why is America radagon why is
radagon America
I don't think we do
all right who's the boss gonna be
oh this is uh
Harry and Manor boy
it's gold poop
excellent
half of the guilty
can I wield this thing
and use Rock sling I can
I can do that
who's Thorn sorcery causes slight blood
loss build up wait on me
hold on hold on folks
all I can use a rock sling now
cool who are you no
stay right there
[Music]
Rock sling sucks
foreign
stay over there
stay over there
this is like one of the small dungeon
bosses
scaled to the apostle
ha
okay that was good that was good that
was good
keep walking slowly
I don't like that attack
for obvious reasons
okay okay oh good
okay okay
excellent
foreign
you think missed translations have
impacted the Lord at all or is it not
something you think happened that much
I I don't know what has caused
infusion
um
I okay I think there's a lot of
there's a lot of theories and that's
kind of all you can make of the game
because
I believe like just just as like a main
lore thing here right
I believe that America gave her great
runes to her children before she
shattered the Elden ring
and it wasn't just
spread out after she shattered it
where a lot of people will say that's
dumb and untrue
and I'm like how
and then they they just they believe
that the shattering meant that they
elected them
after the shattering
you know what I'm saying
so there's a lot of like I don't know if
that has to do with the mistranslations
per se
but there's a lot of like things that
people think
and then
other people say something else and then
it'll cause confusion because they'll
like comment saying something else
you know what I'm saying
why'd she shatter the Elden ring I mean
another like it's all theories you can
go watch my video
um
uh you can either watch queen America's
perfect plan or this theory changes
everything go watch those videos that'll
tell you why I think she shattered the
Eldon ring but it's
there's so many people out there who
just think completely different things
so then it like causes a massive amount
of confusion for everyone you know what
I'm saying
and I really doubt this thing can die
from
build up
[Music]
this fight sucks
well thank you seti
I think the demigods we met are the
survivors she tried to kill the entire
Golden Lion and herself do you think
America want to destroy the greater will
intentionally
I mean if you guys haven't seen my
videos on it go watch it like I made
them about a month ago this theory
changes everything a month ago and then
Queen America's perfect plan like two or
three months ago
um
I think America is technically dead
so radagon's technically dead after she
shattered the Elden ring like when we
mend the Elden ring it's just like her
uh
it's just like a husk of her body that
still can hold the Elden ring but it's
not like it's not her you know what I'm
saying
he's not like there
at least that's what it looks like
I think what her plan was was she
so so think of it it seems like the
greater will
kind of uses these people like America
and radagon as puppets for what they
want right she's the vessel of the Elden
ring that's what she's for right
so
how does America weaken the Eldon ring
without it being so obvious to the
greater will he says I want to give all
of my children who are obviously devout
followers of your greater will of the
golden order right I want to give them
my great runes
or give them the great Runes of the
Elden ring so that they can spread their
influence across more of the world then
the greater wolves like all right that
sounds lit bro that sounds great
and then she just [ __ ] shatters that
[ __ ] and it's like Whoa man
and then all of her kids aren't really
followers as they once thought
throws the greater will off I mean
that's what it seems like to me
you know
foreign
I gotta focus on you
[Music]
okay I got a little Frost up on this one
can't tell if it's rolling or not
bro I hate this
LOL
I just shouldn't do that it doesn't work
he absolutely wants to kill the greater
will
she absolutely does it's why she someone
mentioned huge I think
um it's why she wants huge to make a god
slain weapon for the tarnished that was
her wish to him
I need you to forge a weapon for the
tarnish to kill a God and he does
foreign
are you kidding
[Music]
this is harder than the fire Giant
she killed Goldwyn and seven demigods do
we know that
is the black knife assassins killed
Godwin and then we know of the other
seven from the mausoleums of demigods
but do we know America killed him
do we know why not really
yeah I gotta get used to this fight
that seemed a bit unlucky
okay
[Music]
oh
my God
yeah I love the godskin music
how did the demigods get their rune
I mean we were just talking about that I
believe Queen America gave it to them
and convinced the greater will like hey
it makes sense to give my kids these
these runes so they can spread our
influence across
a wider area I would assume like more
people
and then they said okay
and then she kind of [ __ ] on them
put it in very basic terms
come on
that's not what we want
foreign
[Music]
bro this there's no [ __ ] way
hello
America wanted to return the Ellen ring
to the world she sends the tarnish away
to be ready for the day break the ring
kill a tree kill a god profit
art ruins the remnants of the Elden ring
that's what a lot of people think and I
don't believe that's true
they can be obvious like if we put the
the runes back like we only need two of
them
to technically mend the Eldon ring right
to beat the game she only needs
two to enter the city and put them back
in the Elder ring to be able to to be
mended
I don't think all of them are
like having all of them together to mend
the eldering back together is all that
important
I mean it's important obviously but it's
not like each one being a remnant of it
isn't as important as we think
because I think like it's so hard to
[ __ ] explain this [ __ ]
oh
the runes are remnants of the Elden ring
but I think they weren't
like I don't know if you're saying this
I don't believe they were it all of the
demigods obtained them from the
shattering that's what I'm trying to say
so she shattered the a lot of people
think that she shattered the Elden ring
and then people and her kids obtained it
from the shattering I don't believe
that's true I believe she gave away the
runes
the great runes and then she shattered
the Eldon ring
okay I'm trying not to get near the
abductor it's kind of up to the abductor
I might have to display this extremely
slow
what's the range okay you don't
it doesn't go across the room to hit me
but it sure can
yeah it's hard to have this discussion
and fight at the same time
it's the dungita and then go watch this
theory changes everything that video I
made a month ago
I think America knew that there are more
like the greater will is in every single
Dimension like all of us playing
the game were in our own Dimension I'm
in my own Dimension playing in my
playthrough my
my journey you all have your own and
they're all individually different and
queen America knows that
so for every single ending that you as a
player or in your own dimension
can play through because some of you did
the Ronnie ending some of you did the
flame of frenzy some of you did dung
eaters some of you just went and became
the new Eldon word right but in every
single parallel universe every single
dimension
Wing America knew of their existence
because she is the vessel of the greater
will The Vessel of the Eldon ring she
knows all of this stuff
and she makes it possible to destroy the
greater will in every single dimension
because if we only kill him in one
then it it doesn't affect all of them
so she wants to just either like
Ronnie's ending is leaving the greater
will behind and letting it die the dung
eater is completely replacing it the
gold mask ending is just having nobody
believe in the greater will after we
like that ending to me is the most
complicated one but Corinne just like
literally doesn't believe in the greater
will anymore
uh after that ending which I think is
how it destroys the greater will people
lose Faith and Hope in it
um
all of those right so go watch that
video if you want a much more detailed
explanation but
I believe that's how that is
what's good like what were we talking
about originally man like
why people have so many different
interpretations
and why this is the most complicated
lore
is because of everything we're talking
about like a bunch of people believe one
thing a bunch of people people believe
another thing and in all honesty that's
literally how the real world works like
this it's it's insane like so many
different people have so many different
religions so many different beliefs and
in politics religion all of this
different stuff
and it leads to a bunch of [ __ ] chaos
in the entire world right like it's
crazy
very hard to explain still
let's give this a real shot
God I hate that attack I hate it
[Music]
I'm not saying Elden Ring's real life
I'm saying they they made a lore kind of
based off of it
foreign
you know like what
[ __ ] what ending would you guys pick
that's up to you right [ __ ]
foreign
who you talk to
which bosses you defeat some people like
[ __ ] hate radon but I love radon
because I understood him while other
people won't take the time to understand
him
so and then they still won't like him
you know what I'm saying like or won't
believe in his cause
it's just like real life
Bang Bang
join join myself and Kings I changed the
Super Chat sound
it just cuts right there these streams
are more entertaining than half the
shows on Netflix thank you ah you're
welcome I appreciate that and thank yes
thank you for the five dollars and I'm
glad you think so
I have fun talking about this stuff
obviously I do I wouldn't do it if I did
I'm glad you like it
like the timing like how do I even live
through that
this might be the hardest boss I've come
across
the line to pay respects to the queen is
22 hours long that is crazy
and cool hello hello but thank you again
vintage
I'm really glad you like it
the original topic was which Souls game
has the most complicated lore for all of
these reasons that's why I think Elden
ring has the most complicated lore is it
my favorite lore no
like is it my favorite one to like get
into and talk about and the one that I
digest
like and enjoy the most no
is that a somber no it that's not the
somber we want
oh pain imagine
[ __ ]
we need a three
so bad
no
I hate you
I'm thinking about the mimic I'm
thinking about it
just to kill one you know
all right
by the way that's why I keep killing
that guard
is because he keeps dropping stuff
so I'm Gonna Keep It
but uh I will say though chat like I
have been so lured out
um I haven't made a lore video for Elden
ring in
weeks you know I'm I'm so
like the the lore is so complicated that
like I had to take a break from it
I don't want to take a break from it
because it's what everyone wants to see
on the channel
for obvious reasons
but it just hurts my head
and then there's people like uh vati and
Smoketown making literally the best lore
videos they possibly can exist and it's
like well
foreign
what
it went I didn't even know it could
chain into that attack
you're different from them though I I
know
but I think it's for reasons that a lot
of people I would say 50 of people don't
like
you know what I'm saying
um I theorize
much more than vati and Smoketown do
they do like the lore
that we get in the game and it's like as
factual as it can be right
or an understanding of it as much as
possible
whereas I theorize a lot and 50 of
people
absolutely hate that
yeah
you know what I'm saying they despise it
making any type of guess on anything
so it becomes frustrating
I could try lightning that's a good idea
that's a good idea hold on
cyber 4 again dude dang it
dang it
let me try a different spell because
Rock sling did nothing to these guys
like nothing
what why can't I use lightning sphere
uh excuse me I thought I could
17 Faith
why isn't reading your chat it hasn't
gone through yet I'm waiting for it too
though
it will
sometimes it takes a second
and thank you Trey
I could Electrify it
you think Glenstone Stars would do
anything
I guess I could try all of them
oh I don't have my sore seal on that's
what it is huh I mean I pretty much die
in one hit anyway so
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] it dude
I use this
I didn't even okay
all right
spell
I'm just gonna do lightning
there we go
I have always wanted to hear a British
guy say golly gee what a buttocks
Snickers and biscuits Snickers and
biscuits thank you Trey I appreciate it
man
I appreciate it uh oh I need the emblem
uh oh
oh claw Mark seal is needed whoops
whoops whoops whoops
there you go Trey I hope that's exactly
what you wanted
thank you very much thank you thank you
you should play Dark Souls 3 Sinister I
love that game
bathi does only true lore videos you do
a lot of theories that can be wrong Etc
and it's interesting but body on another
level
uh
you can reach his level I'm sure that I
mean vati
I didn't realize this till recently vasi
has an entire team
of editors of uh like an entire Discord
of people like coming up with lore
um organizing everything
uh all kinds of stuff he I mean he has
people that
do all of his cinematics and things like
all of his really cool shots
everything right and then he does a ton
of work obviously and he's got that big
ass platform
um doing all of this on your own is
extremely hard
extremely hard
well didn't affect you very much did it
give me a somber 3 and this changes the
game for us
hard to catch up I'm not trying to catch
up to vazi I that's not possible you
know it's just not and that's fine
okay that's decent
you
no way he reaches me
that's not bad at all
get me out of here
hello
this is ridiculous
foreign
to dodge this thing
with this going on too
hey have a good one Garrett thanks for
hanging out man
I think we need to go somewhere else
this is way too hard
way too hard bro
how do I boost my bold of grand sacks uh
is there a way to like make it more
powerful like a build around it
um I would just look at this
that I think I have the bolt
don't have the bolt yeah
um attribute scaling strength and decks
and int it looks like just scale those
it'll make it stronger and then
obviously leveling it
tray
with the five gifted members thank you
dude
now you guys get a bunch of
you get five godrics let's go thank you
Trey yeah this is way too hard we need
to leave
if you got a gifted membership from Trey
make sure to say thank you make sure to
say thank you
[Music]
where were we
I guess we can go to nocron
and do the boss up there
Let's do let's do that
but thank you again Trey you're the man
appreciate you
I forgot that you could gift memberships
on here
I actually forgot
and have I not gone South
we need to go this way
get that gifting train going
hey man
I I would like to have more members
in the channel That would be fun
they have the more colorful chat
that's what I like about twitch
now five more people can spam you died
when I die Excellent Man
re-watching the teaser trailer for this
game I noticed green lot friendly was in
it possibly him could be wrong
was he carrying Melania
because that's like his lore isn't it
have I not grabbed the potential physic
down here
swear it did
I swear I did
foreign
no I haven't
ritual pot well we got the physic
that'll help a little bit [ __ ]
is that the whip
I think minabember is awesome
being a member is fun
and it supports the channel don't become
a member if you don't want to support
the channel that's it
but if you want to support go for it
makes wonders physic I have just this
that's right Trey that's right
I should come up with more ways for more
reasons for people to become a member
the you died emote's pretty big
but we'll see
[Music]
I like the whip from the dude that dies
in a pot
oh yeah the um hoslo
yeah yeah
poor fathers one and all
the witness okay this is what I wanted
to grab real quick oh my God it's not a
three
it's not a three I thought it was a
three and I was gonna poop my pants
I was gonna poop
all right let's go in the longest
elevator ride of all time
wait I want to sit closer to the edge
there we go
yeah Juno haslow
I have like I haven't even used the whip
yet
I should
a torben thank you man
thank you for coming for becoming a
tarnished as well you're the man
thank you thank you thank you enjoy the
emotes
you guys seem to only like one emote
but enjoy it
thank you thank you thank you
I don't think you can on YouTube Trey
gifting members is is new in its in and
of itself
it's like completely new
so
YouTube can only get better at it right
yeah I've checked a few cemeteries so if
I could check more
there we go
okay that was a smithing one thank you
again torben
if you remember
spam some you dieds
for torben thank you
maybe I should get a w emote I need new
emotes that you guys actually want to
use besides you died
it was glovework
so if you got any ideas let me know
Briar Gauntlet stone sword key that's
pretty cool
oh God this is a mess
smoldering butterfly
night Grieves
golden Rune this is awful oh my God
Reese spear
that's not bad
that's not bad at all
we got a toot toot over here
I love toot-toot
sacrificial ax golden ruin five
bomb down Giant oh God
oh what are you what are you what are
you
dude
give me the thing Michael is needle okay
it's kind of worthless but whatever
yeah
[ __ ] you
okay
irvy Patrick's fun he is pretty cool
you want a maidenless One
what would a maidenless emote be
cause that's actually kind of funny
enjoy your drugs Cameron enjoy enjoy
a bear witness emo
study what
thank you for becoming a tarnish too
welcome
get some you died and chat
or seti [ __ ] see that would make sense
with the noise we could have a bear
witness emote
and then when somebody becomes a member
we can spam the bear Witness
that makes sense
and it sounds fun
we need to go check this Merchant too he
might have a somber three
stamped like you died but it says
maidenless you think just like the text
would be fine
um
I'll try and remember these
Mainland list could be smiling Vare face
with maidenless under it
man condensing that down into a an emote
would be hard but I like the idea
oh you want a knee heel
could be like a Moog raising up his
thing with a knee heel text in it
the heck
look at these guys are all glowy
I didn't even know they could do that
make a screaming godric's head
you think that would work like you guys
would understand what that is
if it was just his head
honored five excellente
Lampkin what is that
foolish tarnished emote
oh
hmm
okay okay I like the ideas these are
good ideas
okay I already lit that one we got a
worm face literally running back and
forth and it's kind of creepy over there
we got a lobster boy
let me go get this up here
this right here oh God I hate these
dinos bro
Lobster
leave me alone
please
thank you
can I get a taco you guys want a taco
emo
I don't know if that would make sense
whoa whoa whoa damn that was kind of
weird
oh we need a seven huh
that makes sense
hey look there's your taco emo right
there
thank you
yeah we're gonna check the merchant I
just wanted to get all these uh lit
we haven't even got them all we need to
go through uh this thing up here
Ruby
um okay
the [ __ ]
could be a picture of his face screaming
at a dragon head breathing fire beside
him
you yeah I mean you got to remember how
small these are and how hard that would
be you know
because that's a good idea but it would
be so hard to see you know
you should see what this boss is
real quick
archery Avatar huh okay okay
ow
pain
I hope my stream isn't for 144p
it should be 140
or 1440p
damn you do a lot of damage
foreign
I mean I'm dodging bro we good
foreign
oh please don't kill me
ah oh use
you [ __ ]
we need a band emote we barely ever ban
anybody here
yeah
I mean I can check YouTube let's see
because this could be on my end even
though some of you are aren't having
issues
old everybody hold yeah that kind of
sucked you know what I needed to do
there I needed to dodge
I think dodging would have helped
all right guys shut up Jake you [ __ ]
suck all right
see I have the option for 1440 right
there brother
so we should be good
guys like the Stream
okay
like the Stream
like the damn stream
it helps I think I don't really know
just realized I can use torrent here
let me see what this item is real quick
nice
if we ever come across Market we have
the item
s
welcome crusty
where's your video on kicking ass a
couple days ago which one which one
which one
like Moog
I took that one down
the algorithm did not like that video
the stream is still up though but you
can watch it on
it's the last randomizer one toward the
end [ __ ] I need to focus and not die
right at the end again
foreign
[Music]
all right give me something cool
you're gonna give me something cool
right
wow
that's so great
I love cookbooks
no we haven't fought Melania yet
no Melania haven't seen her yeah we know
those guys don't give us anything new
I see the item we're going we're going
yep that cookbook is something all right
all right guys
so nice
what the oh no
this is gonna be so worth it whenever I
get the right angle
it's totally not going to be a cookbook
wow
wow I'm glad I risked my life for that
one
me through
[ __ ] you squirrel
watch great room right here oh that's a
good talisman
greatly raises attack power with
successive attacks
I think we do that
instead of that right now
I wasn't looking
these birds are [ __ ] terrifying
yeah that's an amazing talisman
we take that boys we take that 100
percent
all right what we got cooking in here
anything anything of value anything
uh
uh that was a lot
oh
remembrance of the rock goddess that's a
lot of runes right there
glad I went in there
excellent [ __ ] that crab actually that
crab gets to live
wasn't because I missed oh you [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
how do I get out of here
okay there we go
if I have the remembrance can I buy the
gear
um I can't even talk to the two fingers
yet
it's so no
yup
if I if we can somehow obtain a somber
three
I can literally upgrade to a plus nine
that is the one somber we need and it
will completely change the game for us
right now
hey yo [ __ ] you
yeah I've been to the round table I
can't go in the well actually I have a
great room I thought you needed two you
only need one you're right it is
available now
do we want melania's stuff though
like is it even that good
go buy one
we can't
you forehead
for some reason I thought you needed two
great rooms you only need one I'm
thinking of the other thing all right
everybody
I don't care if you believe in religion
or not
pray that he has a somber 3 right now
put your hands in the air and believe
that he has it
and we also need a forehead emo that is
true oh
come on baby
come on baby
come on baby
damn it
you had a golden seed though goodbye
till next time [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
damn
foreign
we already went to the the castle we
already went to the academy
we don't need the key
we don't need it boys oh God
you should fight [ __ ]
um
uh that is like way down the quest line
my guy
oh we need to go this way
we need to fight this boss
wait where's the is the teleporter right
here
here it is
yeah man we have no idea if [ __ ] will
be there we want to go to the boss room
obviously
we're gonna do this
yes
Everything is randomized Everything
you get random items for the remembrance
yep I just found melania's remembrance
randomly
like over there just laying on the
ground
so true true
imagine if the teleporters were random
thank you
man Krusty knows what he wants dude
to check and see what's over here as
well there's some items
this way
you never know it could be a somber
three
what's your favorite weapon
my favorite playthrough was when we did
the Rick 100 playthrough oh you cook
Lord
stop teasing me
damn it
my heart skipped a beat
is there anything here
[Music]
I think there's another item
then isn't there like a no there isn't
isn't there like a hidden cave over here
yeah
we could go see what the twin gargoyles
fight is
as well
the best weapon equals dodging ah
great I love that for us
how do you get that helmet I have no
idea we randomly got it somewhere
because it's a randomizer
wait which uh which thing did I miss
it's probably the ones like right here
which porch did I miss
um
um it's the one up here
yep I did not get this one
I was thrown off by this fire
60 drug purchase later what'd I miss
you missed everything
should I feel bad for just randomly
killing goats
get a sticker that says behold dog you
mean an emote
see what's over here real quick
oh we need a sneeze emote I sneeze all
the time
uh
and a burpee emote
we have a lot of ideas for any months
actually
okay
I even go oh yeah I can oh yeah I can go
down here
yep you get to watch the stream again
and give me another view let's go whoa
grab
God damn it
why does it keep doing that to me man
give me a song or three
oh that squirrel [ __ ] that goat [ __ ]
this deer
what did I miss
huh
wait what did I not even light that no I
did like that
huh
huh
the lights on my left
where
I lit that
I lit that one up there
guys am I stupid
don't answer that
I lit that one
it's one in the far back oh I didn't
like this one what the heck
I must have gotten scared
there was a somber on the ground how do
you know that
you're just special in your own way
thank you Mom
oh it's a dumbass map
like I don't know where I'm going at
this point
all right who's the boss who's the Boss
what your guess is in now
put your guess is in
I'm gonna run Arc it
s [ __ ] fortisac somebody said it too
crusty got it
[Music]
okay this is actually really cool as
well
this like works
ow
fire hurt body
oh this is not good boys this is not
good
oh this man do not like ghost flame
though
[Music]
I do not know the timing of that at all
give me that Noggin
foreign
[Music]
this is really cool I like the music
with this
the colors don't match as well as ranola
did but it's still cool
I got scared
I got very scared
oh
I am I am I am that I am a god
why literally a genius at the game
how am I alive
oh
I don't even know what my physic is
what
let me drink
since every alcoholic ever
oh boy
I I literally non-stop ran
all right this is it
[Music]
what
what no no
I can't see
ah there's death everywhere he has no
health bar
first try
wow a golden seed
that's great
I love that I probably can't even
upgrade
so worth
God
first try though that was pretty cool
not bad at all yep it's basically like
you get a gold star good for you man
[Laughter]
wow
enjoy your your gold star
hey thanks man
did I not um
no Cron
yeah we need to go here
participation award
um the natural resources in caves are
also randomized grimp
I need more vigor
let me some out no yeah I don't even
have enough golden seeds let's go
okay let's go see what we can get from
melania's remembrance
have a good one vintage
of great time
get up shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up shut up
so pray seek to become a letter
he talks so much
up now we're gonna get bots
oh my God can you imagine if she had a
somber 3 dude
guys we don't even get what we want
enhances jump attacks oh man
[ __ ]
I'll go forth
dang it
all right I guess I should just use it
huh
oh I have a lot of sellies
yeah I don't know what Eldon remembrance
had you're right dang it I should have
waited
I should have waited you're right
so all these bad boys
um I don't think there's any other point
I don't think we want that
yeah I'm just gonna sell it that's a lot
of runes
okay
um should I keep like trying to do in
intelligence
I love grilled cheese
I mean that makes my weapon better I'm
gonna do this
our build sucks
makes a lot of sense for it to suck
though
it's on sourdough
oh
okay
we already bought those
yep yep yep
there's another seed which I will buy
because I think we can get one now like
an upgrade
that's a somber 5 which we already have
dang it
lasts add charge we'll take it at least
I don't think our physics Really Gonna
help that much to the htbh
t b h let's go see what the uh
let's go see what the double gargoyle
fight's gonna be
because that should give us a
significant amount of runes too
buy the nft no
oh you know what I did recently chat I
invested
like in stocks I felt so adult-like
I felt so adult
I invested in grilled cheese do you
think that was good
yep invested in stocks
I put ten thousand dollars in Kraft mac
and cheese
pretty Worth right
but they also make the cheese slices for
grilled cheese
or should I remember for a grilled
cheese emote
um you know what is this our first meme
that you guys are gonna do a lot of
oh
if so
nah I haven't seen enough grilled cheese
in chat to make it a thing sorry
if more people hop on the train Maybe
grilled cheese equals profit that's what
I'm saying
foreign
which probably has grilled cheese in
there
it's an index one
it's like one of those things you can
invest in that like can't go wrong you
know I mean it can
but it has the least likelihood too you
know I mean
all right what do we got over here
made a little bit
I mean with everything that's going on
right now I mean makes sense
this is my first investment though it
literally did it yesterday
from all of the advice I've gotten it's
like
if you put money in the S P 500 you
won't get like you know it won't be like
insane but you'll get
like just based on
it's
history it will go up
yeah nothing's doing good that's true
oh God
it's one of these Mausoleum guys yeah it
is
what the hell
thing is huge
excuse me
I feel like we do need a burp and a
sneeze emote
gotta pick up everything you never know
all right is this crying loser gonna be
here
you know [ __ ] you
all right I don't care let's go
all right who we got
I already fought oh it's the second
stage fire giant oh God
oh God
are you [ __ ] kidding me
I I can't use torrent
I I can't use torrent yeah what's the
other guy gonna be because there's two
bosses in here
oh my God this is gonna suck
this might be impossible
it's gonna be Melania
this mod does heat
okay bro
bro excuse me
this is ridiculous
if I hit his hand
hey yo [ __ ] your eye [ __ ]
I just did that did that you have no
idea how impressive that was right there
actually you all probably do
foreign
his timing is so annoying
foreign though
that was probably a bad idea yes it was
yes it was
[Music]
I'm nuts
never mind
roll off the cliff damn it
that timing is annoying
nice
big damage
oh [ __ ] I forgot
no idea how I lived no clue
that can come down and hit me
this is going quite well so far
God damn it
okay
oh the water makes us trippy bro I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
dude
this fight isn't designed without
torrent man
this fight isn't designed without
torrent it doesn't look like there's
another one at least
there may not be a second any second is
Red Bull for radagon became the Valiant
gargoyles of radagon
Maybe
bam is right leg
[Music]
and he's all fired up
I hate myself
well that's a awful start to say the
least
man rolled away
that joke was cheesy
okay got him procked
something
yeah I don't think I can just Spam them
you know
that was bad
that's annoying
what what what he has a fast he has a
faster version
of that attack
son of a [ __ ]
I feel like it's doable though we we
kind of have to get lucky that he
doesn't do some [ __ ]
what you guys don't like cheese flavored
cheese it's pretty good
never had cheese flavored cheese
got the balls
we're alive we're alive we're alive
excellent
oh oh cool I'm glad I get to make this
run again I like that
okay I mean we got him proctored
uh sus
that was pretty good
that is like not even worth trying
foreign
that didn't seem to do more I don't even
know if I hit him there
man
I mean I need more FP nope I'm dead
please please stop wow okay it's
dodgeable if I just go to the side
that's good to know
actually good to know
we're getting better at the dodges
that was bad
foreign
getting better at the dodges
nice
[ __ ] I jinxed it
luck
that was luck
that is not luck
damn it
okay
bit unlucky we're getting a bit unlucky
right now
definitely
foreign
if we need another attempt we need to do
that
let's go Trey happy Friday
mimic will do nothing
it's not even worth doing anything on
the mimic
[ __ ]
okay
somewhat cool with this I think
I wish I got to be able to hit his head
can't always have what we want you know
couldn't even see what he was doing
excellent
I had no stamina to roll
not good boys
okay let's put a couple more flasks in
FP and I think we're good
and no I've never I have not gotten the
somber three it I would love a somber
three we could beat this guy in one try
if we get literally one somber
one one more somber three we can level
all the way to nine and we're basically
can beat the game from there
I didn't change
I got distracted I got distracted I got
distracted
we'll quit out go again
I don't have a grilled cheese mod
you guys are trying to make grilled
cheese a thing and I don't think it's
gonna happen guys
I don't think it's gonna happen
grilled cheese DLC
I love it
I love it man
my ass allocate I'm literally I'm gonna
put two more in it
you just want you want it to be
something so bad that I don't think it
can happen
I think it can
I can't control what Miyazaki does
I am not Miyazaki
what up Tim
I have no control over Miyazaki okay
although I will take a grilled cheese
DLC
you think I'm Miyazaki
oh can I use this guy
no I don't have his armor
I need Dee's armor to have him help in
this fight
no help
yes yes a fellow member
all right he's gonna start out with the
Balls of Fury
we gotta run to the left
excellent
this ball is really annoying
could not ever get close enough
that wasn't bad
that's bad
foreign
for this
okie dokie
very good roll
whoa
whoa
what the [ __ ] was that
complete unluck
no luck
I I actually just got newt
I got newt
Dodge shut the [ __ ] up Johnny
no
no tits in my ass tits in my ass
I don't know if the big nuke is worth
the FP cost
yeah this does enough
what is he doing okay
killing me that's what he's doing
thank God his foot doesn't have a hitbox
oh no
buck
dodging every [ __ ] spell in the book
a lot of hits
foreign
I might be too far away okay there we go
there nice 1400 damage
I don't know what he's doing okay oh
we'll get that toe right there nice
we're getting that epic toe damage
I think we got some balls coming in
balls are in
that's pretty dumb oh we're spamming it
huh
but you go [ __ ] yourself
fat [ __ ] that's right
okay that's not usually what he does
it's really annoying
no okay
I panicked
he's still getting hit by it though
that's fine
okay run this way
okay so I'm dead I guess all right cool
holy [ __ ] I already hated the fire giant
fight and this is just this makes it
exponentially worse
I got grilled
okay Walter White
I am the one who knocks
how much Vigor not enough
the answer is not enough
like 25.
okay bro
okay big dog
oh okay
cool
right right right because because that
made sense
so is there just like a hitbox that
insta kills you on his role
because I've been hit by the roll many a
Time
and have not died
foreign
God I hate this guy
I hate him
okay that's something
foreign
I tried to get on the inside so I could
hit his eye it didn't work obviously
how was he so fast
okay this either insta kills me or I run
to the left and we're fine
cool
really
really
okay I hit his hand
bro I don't get it
please don't spit Your Fire
[Music]
uh oh
we get nuked boys
I can't tell what he's doing
look at that ass
look at that ass
I mean
[Music]
foreign
getting more successive hits
save me rock
we've been saved by The Rock
you Dwayne Johnson
cool
I love that for me
cool
he has started to spam attacks
excellent we don't talk about that
thank you
nice
we'll take it we'll take it
foreign
foreign
what
I'm just hitting the leg we're going for
the leg successive attack damage
that's all I can do at this point
okay nope
this is gonna suck without FP boys
yo what up Kyle
foreign
I really don't want to die
that was risky
so much fire
come on
yeah
[Music]
be dead
great we got the curse mark of death
that's great we can see what Forte sacks
is doing
Kyle Even you want to real cheesy moat
God damn it
all right fair enough
I need more Vigor clearly
if you keep the grilled cheese thing
alive
you can have a grilled cheese emote
I've been good Kyle
how about you
how's work
well Kyle can get whatever he wants
even though he won't even be able to use
I don't think Kyle's a member
press one in chat if you want a grilled
cheese emote
if you spam it you don't get one
three I see a three
God I look so dumb
got a job over down by the beach so now
I'm just working to get to that point
awesome man good for you
seven see not even everyone wants one
yeah see seven eleven you can get a
seven emote no we don't say seven that
much
the only time we do seven is when
someone super chats
and they just type a bunch of sevens
foreign
butterfly
I think that actually replaced the
archery Avatar
flowing curved sword lamb
yeah this dog definitely scaling with
that Urban Tree Avatar
excellent
okay maybe not maybe not
this is annoying this is very annoying
what do you give me
not worth it at all
not even a little bit
hey have a good one Kyle thanks for
stopping by man
I recently picked this game back up
after a few months I just killed godric
stuck on renala and still am
do I have to fight her or go somewhere
else you do not have to fight ranala
Ronaldo is technically an optional boss
she is one of the easier bosses though
unless you are a magic build
which in that case she is very resistant
to Magic
we definitely need like a sneeze or a
bless you emote or something I I'm I
sneeze all the time that's Cavalry Helm
be still sling
Waldron 10.
your nicotine tolerance is garbage
then you say you're cracking a cigar
I don't know about a grilled cheese I'm
not sold on that yet
what are fia's champions gonna be
oh God I almost fell
basically only use sorcery until I got
to Ronaldo yeah I mean she's so
resistant she's like what is it 90 magic
resistant
I think
Arrow we're getting a lot of armor right
here I like that
we got the map
telling you what changes our entire game
is a somber three whoa
[ __ ] Imp in here bro
Crucible Knight Duo
uh destroy and create space
the fight is gonna be hard no matter
what
we got a cemetery over here that we
probably want to hit real quick
roxling go Burr
roxling is very good
for five
or not summer fives smithing five
carrion oh that's good that's a good
Talisman well two
golden ruin and a Lord's Rune that's a
lot of runes another rune
and oh flavors okay
very interesting weapons
I need a somber three bro so bad
let's go see what uh BS Champions are
Melania Moog and fia's radagon
oh well radagons where the golden not
the golden the
godskin Noble is in volcano Manor so I
don't think he can show up in another
spot
this is another really good item
sweep the darkness and now Newman's room
okay okay okay
oh I gotta check this
something's dying over there somehow
smithing six
I can't believe how rare a smithing
somber 3 is it's kind of insane
this is getting out of hand at this
point
oh God
did I just see what I thought I saw in
there
what do you want me to do stop right now
and make a somber three
or make a grilled cheese emote
is that [ __ ] Reichard
phase two
are you kidding
just standing there
will this even work in here
God he is small compared to Godwin
this is weird
why is he just standing here is this
via's champions
this doesn't even work
are you kidding
maybe it has to trigger the fight yep
be is right card is there gonna be more
this is this is absurd
I'm already at the edge
how am I already at the edge
the whole Edge is fire man
oh my God
I can't look
I ca I can't see
I don't know what's happening
please don't use that bull I I literally
can't move Chad
I think I just dodged that okay
well this is [ __ ] dumb
what I I thought like you can't even use
the Full Arena
you can't stand in lava and spam L2
you'll you'll just
it doesn't work like that
oh God
you'll get uh knocked
it's only visual I was clearly getting
hit by it right
really you can
get so close
why does that do no damage hello
why is this doing no damage
that that attack does no damage for some
reason what the heck
oh that's pure
like why is my R1 doing less damage or
more damage than my loaded art l2s
foreign
that's something
I don't know what's going on right now
but this is just garbage
why did that hurt me
awesome
foreign
what
it is hologram lava why though
is it just for the boss room in the
normal fight
I got smushed
I got schmooshed I don't have a bow
I do have a bow but it's not gonna do
anything it's not gonna make a
difference let me try with a normal
weapon
try hitting him from outside the arena
since it's not loaded in
where's my poker
hello
where the [ __ ] my poker
huh
oh it's right here okay
I mean like sneak to the side
does it mean like this
he was toes clinch the [ __ ]
it's not hurting them
[ __ ]
oh yeah this is way better okie dokie
well it's not much better now
why did it randomly do a lot of damage
and then not so much
like did it just proc them that fast
look at the sounds dude
Howie
oh no FB still works though
all right is this better or not
okay
what is that oh it's like the fire
explosions it's the fire so the Fire
doesn't do anything but the random
explosions do
cool got it that's awesome I love that
I love that for us
what is that a little coffee maker oh a
little air fryer
my mom sent me an air fryer
uh
sorry I'm looking at my phone for the
first time
will the stream be up on the channel of
course
of course
yeah this fight's really bugged
do you like Snapple I used to like
Snapple until I realized how much sugar
is in Snapple it's insane
it's a lot of sugar
so should I switch between these two
maybe
it's not gonna make me oh yeah I might
be Nike
oh yeah this is what we all like to see
huh
this is what we all like to see
mm-hmm
I can't see I don't think this is even
worse
this is just like instantly better
and I'm dead
let's do it
I think an R1 spam with this
I can't even see where those are coming
from
foreign
holy [ __ ] this is so broke
man's just backed up bro
man's a giant God devouring snake and
he's backing up for me
I think he was legit bugging right there
you guys think there's gonna be two
other boss fights after this one
oh I'm at the gate
okay switch
foreign
die please
okay we did that I don't think it's done
okay it's done
demigodfeld guys demigodfeld
oh faith not Blasphemous claw and a
sobber Age of Dragon smithing Zone
that'll be good for plus 10 if we could
get a [ __ ] plus three if we
could get a somber three then that would
be great that would be amazing but we
can't get a somber three
sorry if that was really loud I was
right in the microphone
what is the Blasphemous claw for
he sounds like Kermit
no this sounds like Kermit you [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
okay
level one time
use it against malakath
deflecting maleket's blade that's right
okay sorry I was right in the microphone
again
I'm not really sorry about it
let's get that up
you can Parry
that attack it's kind of lit all right
I'm kind of over the head
that we've been using
the weird head
uh
yo what a fit
we out here with a fit right now
Bia where are you
you're not even here
what's your opinion on the tree setting
armor looks pretty lit ain't gonna cap
it's pretty cool armor I don't think
I've even talked a few yet let's go down
here oops
that that's what I had planned a big
reason why this is the last
um
the last randomizer stream is because I
have to delete the randomizer to be able
to record normal gameplay
or videos
which is like you know I could just
stream for the next like months straight
and be okay but
I kind of wanted to start making lore
videos again but
or we could just stream you know what
I'm saying
hey I got the frilled finger guys I
finally got it it's like the first thing
you get in the main area awesome
but I have to delete the randomizer or
else everything's just random all the
time
all right who we got here is that the
tree Sentinel
it's the draconic tree Sentinel
excellent stay right there okay
oh it's just in the tree signal
I thought it was draconic
you are as strong as hell
foreign
big hits from this one
yeah I I found that even when you turn
the randomizer off it still [ __ ] your
game
so I have to like fully delete it
and I didn't want to like fully delete
it
because I didn't want to lose progress
on what we've been doing you know what
I'm
saying
a second PC what
no that's really hard to do
I should have died I should have died
foreign
oh come on yeah I'll just buy another PC
I'll just do that
that's probably not what you meant
foreign
oh bro that fight was already so long
die die right there damn
no they're here
they finally came
these [ __ ] stacks
where is my mouse there we go
it did kind of look sick
it's already another one
no it only took four hours
all right imagine this drops a somber
three though like that's just all I
think here is Imagine This random boss
drops exactly what we need
this is basically just the Quest for
somber three
could fight you on torrent now that's
not already going well hello what the
heck is that
what
okay I don't like fighting You On Target
[Music]
three nope that that was bad
set up a virtual machine and Run the
game on that
I mean hey what would you guys rather
want me to make
videos or for me to stream
I'm fine with either one
I think I like streaming more than I
like making videos to be totally honest
with you
I wish I could stream and those turn
into videos but the algorithm does not
like it when I do that
[ __ ]
okay let's try this again
he does look really cool in this
lighting
he matches
going off
still doing the grilled cheese why not
both
I mean okay I mean I can
but like I just said if I want to record
normal videos I have to delete the
randomizer
I tried to find a way to do it without
deleting it and I couldn't find one
I think that would be a nice update but
I wouldn't call it like a major update
to give torrent armor it would be cool
though
I think they should
oh well torrent's Dead all right
that timing is just absurd all right
jeez
sometimes his timing windows or
like impossible
finish the randomizer then make vids
you have a Talisman for horseback damage
is it that good
[ __ ] it let's try it let's see if
there's a significant difference
you want a Leonard skin so basically
torrent looking like a corpse
you know I'm still getting comments from
my radon video of people correcting how
I say his name
it's not Leonard it's Leonard obviously
do you not even know English
I've heard the name Leonard before and
I'm like Leonard sounds so basic why
wouldn't it be Leonard
yeah damage is okay
oh
that's bad
hello
15 huh okay okay
awesome timing I love that for me
Leonard is a bro's name or Leonard is
good night Krusty
I might just go to the chest behind him
looks like I can just run past them
is it really Leonard
why would it be Leonard I really want
clarification on that
that sounds so dumb
oh
my God I thought
I thought
yeah another somber seven I think that's
like seven at this point or five
I need to be on touring
thank you torrent for taking that hit
why is this so hard all of a sudden
like I've beaten this guy well actually
he's scaled to be extremely strong so
that makes sense never mind
I'm just getting hit by everything right
now holy crap
okay one one more good try
it has nothing to do with the hat
I hope
[Music]
foreign
are you actually kidding
I couldn't move at all
one swipe knocks torrent and then you
are totally stuck
and he could just blast you into the
ground
all right if this makes a difference
I don't even know what I'll do
I don't think the horseback Talisman is
worth it all
so hard to control torrent
foreign
what the [ __ ] is that
okay I'm over it I don't even want to
fight him anymore
I'd rather fight reichardt in an
enclosed area than fight him again
hi panda
yeah horseback Talisman Lance enhances
attacks on Horseback I don't really need
it though
oh I kind of need that though okay
let's go down here
see what we can get
are there any bosses down here
technically I still would be down here
joust him I think we were just doing
that and it did not work
if the game took place on Earth what
country do you think it would take place
in
Finland I don't know
I don't know
nowhere
on some other planet
nope nope nope
all right who replaced this guy over
here
item here Bruce will not Talisman okay
a bunch of runes and a summon
one little golden Rooney boy
best not the best
we're in Ark
excellent
this little fire guy
foreign
this is great
I think he's touring here
I'll be able to upgrade our mimics here
summon
oh that was the train is Lily never mind
we got a [ __ ] stick I love that for
us
at least there aren't a bunch of ants in
here
that's cool
golden room golden 13 Celestial do we
are finding a lot of runes right now
that's good
The Twig lets you die without losing
your runes if you put it in your
Talisman slot
yep
this area is so pretty
I guess we can see what's up there
infinitely no it it's one use
what the [ __ ] going on up there why
are they so aggro oh my God
what's going on here man
y'all need to cut it out
nope wrong window
keep going
[ __ ] y'all
yep we found an ant
oh my God stop
it needs to stop
like how is there just never a somber 3
dude oh
oh
so I just do a jumping attack on him and
his animation yeah okay cool that's cool
man
that's real that's real neat how he can
just jump in the air after I dive on his
forehead
look at all these guys aggro right here
we'll see once I get past this Arch boom
they're coming
you gotta be
I'm opening the chest
nice
foreign
we haven't even gotten that far into
renala
some not really
um
that light shining from
yep I got a dress that's real great huh
we love that huh
keep doing the randomizer until you get
somber three
the Quest for soccer 3.
[ __ ]
scimitar
uh
uh Valiant gargoyles
the two gargoyles terrible fight
Dragon wound grease that was not worth
it at all
and you guys really like these streams
huh
that's good
hmm
so I'll tell you what I am not super
inspired
to make lore videos right now but I love
streaming
ow
oh
I just want this
you know he's got a lot of runes
who's that
he looks so cool oh is that
is that Rick
what is happening in here
okay
I hate you
stagger do it
you [ __ ]
that's what I want
real cheese lore video huh
that's what you guys want to see
with how many enemies are in here one of
them's gotta have a somber three
one of those [ __ ] disappeared
why are there so many
why do you do so much damage
man you [ __ ] slap hard
it's Rick
I'm sorry Rick
what the [ __ ] are you
I did all of that for that
fine
how are there so many enemies in there
man
you hate The Crucible night in Lim grave
interesting
I'm not going back
the runes aren't worth
5K runes isn't
it it is nothing newest now
go up here real quick
is that a that's a big ass wolf what the
[ __ ]
how are you not getting
odd anything other than a damn dog
let's have the dog back up every time
you have a chance to attack
cool
dude
come on
Rick's nemesis
sweet kind of weapon is it there you go
great sword
some other interesting additions
things you can do with it
please don't kill me just just let me go
just let me
please
that's what it says
I mean it has the same like attacks as a
great sword when I'm swinging it
it's pickle Rick
it gets pickle Rick I'm a pickle it's
pickle Rick okay
I'm done
and are we going to be able to get
through this next area because there are
so many enemies
stallion lovely I love that for us
we got some gauntlets
please don't give me blood Shadow thank
you
hammer
thank you
that's a great sword swing yeah
final boss fight I haven't even seen
Ronnie yet
Ronnie ain't there brother
I love the map I'm the map on the map on
the map what the [ __ ] is that oh my God
are you serial
run away away run away run away
I think we don't live through this area
I don't think we live
I don't think we can survive
okay
awesome I love that
bye Panda have a good one
wide Shadow usually shows up right there
I just have not done Ronnie's questline
so he is not there
that's all
oh boy I don't know if I have any rot
things
check right now do
that is luck that we had won we had a
single one it was meant for this moment
let's go
because I don't think I would have made
it here
foreign
location if you don't do Ronnie's
questline
oops
okay
just a large bear
you calm down
God the animations of killing the pots
are just so unnecessarily like insane
it it just can't do it to me more man it
it just can't
trying to hurt my feelings at this point
a cookbook
all right let's go see what astel
is
leave me alone Bloody Dog
for out thou trash
at thy game
yeah the Laker route sucks
all right who do you guys think it is
place your bets place your bets
and will the reward be a somber three
red wolf
you guys all want Melania
oh this is gonna be annoying as [ __ ]
Red Wolf Natural Born of the Void
foreign
foreign
[Music]
I think he might be too quick
look at that oh
foreign
thought hold on
foreign
nice
wouldn't let me stab him okay that was
really easy
oh we could go to the city
we could go to the capital city now
let's go
let's go
yes we have two great rooms
yes
very nice
foreign
that's a big
oh look at all this we got too
[Laughter]
me
God damn
let's get our Vigor up
if only we had a somber 3
couldn't be me
okay that fight was really easy I had a
weird thought that like doesn't isn't
radagon considered a champion
like a tarnished Champion is that what
that means
because I remember Muriel calling him a
mere Champion
Gideon I've killed two gods and I've
talked to them like how are you still
right here
has the same movement from radagon like
the timing yeah
way to say new items are available
let's go check
there he is nope he's still not standing
in there
is that a glitch
cartoon
nope
nope
shop three
nope
you I'm gonna buy that
makes consecutive attacks grow stronger
I actually want that
because of our talisman
you are a somber 5. annoying
okay
oh
Slumber two that's annoying AF
[Music]
eight nine and nine
and nothing helpful this could be cool
but it requires 40 and 18 Faith that's
insane
yeah Gideon looks great look at that
look at her
I don't want the Scarlets here
don't these guys look great
the dog Pope doesn't know who radagon is
why do you say that because he
definitely does he tells us the most
information about him
calls him a mere champion and that he
came on a golden
something Golden Boat I think
forget the exact terminology he uses
there
ah
shut up the
see I think I want he's consecutive hits
he's just dodge rules I don't really
care about that
whose Faith No
came on a golden boat
there's some terminology I just don't
remember exactly what he said
like a golden I mean we could go talk to
him
he's over here
even gold Mass doesn't know no guys
goldmass knows who radagon is and he
knows who Queen America is what he
didn't know is that radagon is America
come on
Monk
it's not like you'd really say anything
but
it's very clear that the lands between
know who radagon is and they know new
know who America is but they don't know
the secret which is that radagon is
America
foreign
bear was in Rick's normal spot
you can make him explode what do you
mean
who is barking
going no happy
oh giggity giggity gotcha
that's you
you're upstairs barking in my living
room
got one of those Queens over here is
this gonna be a boss fight
it's where it's heavy a mariner would be
yep
it's gonna be a Maggie
oh well tits
don't you just get bored and head back
to the first area you find in the game
to start killing people
I wouldn't say so not me
radagon is patches I think we has anyone
given up on trying to understand the
lore
like press one and chat if you just like
kind of given up I've at least taken a
break
oh God my heart
because I needed a break man it's it's a
lot trying to understand this game
foreign
my hardest currently
mm-hmm
don't forget to talk to Bach he misses
his mother that actually made me talk to
Bach I felt so bad ignoring him oh
I've done his quest not in this
playthrough but I have
were the other games this unclear until
dlc2
uh not I would say not this unclear
um
somewhat actually yeah a bit
Dark Souls 3 DLCs were announced early
Dark Souls 3 launched in March of 2016
and their first DLC was in October
and then their second DLC was in like
March or April of the next year
they had two DLCs and that was it
am I still gonna get the painting nope I
get the ritual shark we should go to
these paintings and get like whatever we
need
all right where's Muriel I'm lost
put Muriel over here is that the yeah
that's the Church of vows up there I
think
I wonder if it will be Muriel
that's another question mark
bloodborne wasn't unclear in fact the
DLC made things even more confusing
uh in some ways that's true yeah
no we did not handgun that was
absolutely unreal
I think the dog Pope will be okay
we could switch to night time and see
who would be in here as well
no no he only comes out at night
Muriel was sleeping hello
hello
snail
I don't think Muriel would be any
different doesn't look like it
you missed your [ __ ]
okay
okay okay okay okay
hello Muriel you are tarnished
do you know how it came well the shatter
it is here by the matrimonial bond
between red-haired radican and
red-haired Radigan
and so our church holds in view the
Earth tree of the capital
oh was this you are free I would say if
you find unless in which case I will
about radagon you wish to know more of
Lord Radigan Lord Radigan was a great
champion
possessed of flowing red law what does
Champion mean came to these lands at the
head of a great golden host great golden
host we met lady Ronaldo in battle
soon repented his territorial
aggressions there
and became husband to the karian queen
however when Godfrey first Elden Lord
was hounded from the lands between
banished by America to return to the
Earth tree capital
return America's second husband so
that's where he came from taking the
title of second Elden Lord
the mystery endures to this day as to
why Lord Radigan would cast lady Ronaldo
aside break her heart and cause her to
go insane why a mere Champion would be
chosen for the seat of golden Lord
all right
isn't that interesting
about Ronaldo you wish to know more of
late she is Queen head of the Korean
royal family and Governor like what in
regards to radagon what does Champion
mean beautiful full moon witch champion
of what her heart was broken when Lord
Radigan left her and then
when the academy rebelled against the
Royals she was locked that would tell us
so much like why is he considered that
I have a prayer book
give God skin prayer books what have we
here
very well let us both learn together
heresy is not native to the world
it is but a contrivance
all things can be conjoined
interesting
still gives me these same things huh do
you possess any Celestial Dew amen I
don't [ __ ] know these are the
questions man the champion of the
greater will maybe was he already the
champion because he wasn't the Elden
Lord before she banished Godfrey and
then he he was chosen to be Territorial
aggressions and swore his love to
granola the order of the earth tree and
the fate of the moon were conjoined and
all the wounds of War forgiven the
wounds of war between radagon and
Ronaldo this is what the the church is
for
example to restore any bond however
strained to its rightful state of
Harmony
what do you mean that guy talk my faith
does not waver
the miracle rooted in these grounds
will once again mend the world
and this time
its Bounty will not be squandered if you
would be Eldon Lord
tarnished I hope that you too will share
my faith
that is so interesting okay about the
miracle experience the miracle yeah we
are we know that Absolution will be
yours any bond any bond No matter how
strange or even severed will be put to
rights
one guy leaves you and you go insane
with heartbreak
um I mean I don't think you've been in
love before then
be as Champions Alexander Wants To Be A
Champion and term it's a term used a few
times a game and I take them in the
great warrior and Defender
right
but is it like a
is it
a position
or is it just like a term loosely used
right
maybe radagon became America when he
cleansed himself and Celeste you'll do
here at the church happened right before
he gets with ranala
I mean
isn't it known that ranala hates America
or I guess that's just a theory because
there are no statues America
in the academy which that was theorized
like because he hates her because he
took she took radagon away from her
right
hello
non-binary I don't know if that matters
Ronaldo was a champion before she went
crazy yeah we get to see how powerful
she was from
Ronnie's manifestation of her most
powerful form
but as we know the real Ronaldo is just
locked in a library going nuts
he was a yeah he's a dodging that's why
he's a champion he can just dodge
obviously
hold on it's said that Lord Radigan
harbored a secret oh a famed sculptor of
the earth tree Capital was once summoned
to render Lord radican's likeness in
Giant stature this is the tip
closet and as such it said that the
great statue Harbors his secret too
but when did this secret come to be
right
like was radagon always America
or
was he at one point separate from her
and then it became a secret when they
combined together somehow
right
I have that's why I know it's BS sure
you're sad at first but how long has
this [ __ ] been crying about it 200
years
I don't know it clearly messed her brain
up bro like
there's really no point in being like
wow that's pathetic it's like yeah kinda
it doesn't really matter though
they just locked her in a library and
her her daughter ranola or Ronnie has to
like protect her with a spell
because she like can't defend herself at
all this is weird
it's still sad
I'm saying radagon was just a champion
in the war and he cleansed himself here
America took that as an opportunity to
merge her soul with radagons and then
marry Ronaldo to end the war
so you're saying like America was the
one who wanted to end the war that way
then why would she why would she call
ratagon back
if that's the case
maybe the greater will called radagon
back in America didn't want that
like it might have not been her
they also could have been together for
an extremely long time too
it's so hard to understand how they're
the same being but also two different
beings and like
what I would like to know is can one
take control of the other whenever like
can radagon take control of America's
body and
brick people into thinking
what America's doing is actually what
radagon is doing does that make sense
and vice versa
like if we could know that that would
answer so many questions or like at
least
you know
put it more into perspective of like
what it is
bye Leo have a good one
might have been their plan all the time
to become each other in the end
um here's what I think
there's a bit of a misunderstanding on
well isn't it told that radagon tried to
fix the Eldon fix the shattered Elden
ring after America
shattered it
was that the greater will doing that
with radagon's body
or was that actually radagon you know
what I'm saying
it says it I believe in America's hammer
or something that radagon tried to mend
it with the hammer right
I mean I can look that up
let's just turned into a lore stream
let's see
uh
blundering Wiki
it's I'm pretty sure it's America's
hammer
yes
Maybe
uh Stone Hammer made in the lands of the
Newman the tool which Queen America
shattered the Elden ring and radagon
attempted to repair it
hmm
probably oblivious probably
maybe Lefty but
I don't know
you think it's actually radagon trying
to fix it
I mean that would kind of make sense to
his new like Persona right like he's
trying to mend all wounds with the
celestial do right and that's the whole
point of the Church of vows is to
accept one another in the two big
factions with the carrion Empire and the
golden order
like that's what what it's all about
that's what Muriel's all about and then
America shatters it and he tries to fix
it right that would kind of make sense
with like his new wanting to just kind
of mend everything
radagon America may represent the same
splitty of the fingers there was
somebody in uh Discord who made a pretty
interesting uh
Theory
that the golden order you guys know yin
and yang like the the circle with the
white and the black and you need like
balance of each to have balance in the
world
someone was like that's what the golden
order and the flame of frenzy is like
one is Yin and one is Yang and that's
how you create balance
is having both
and it seems like the Church of vows was
like that peaceful balance between it
seems like
the carrion Royals and the golden order
but I don't know how the flame of frenzy
goes into that
but kind of makes sense get in gang
like two different two different halves
creating a whole
foreign
avatars have completely separate lives
and have their own minds so radagon
could have a full anatomy of himself
despite being a Shard of America
avatars have completely separate lives
that's interesting
melna quotes America saying something
about radagon not yet becoming her
is that what she says or does she say
my other half
I think I know what you're referring to
Oh no you're right she says uh
have yet to become me right
something like that it's
hard to remember all this [ __ ]
hey
together
thank you just stopping by to say hello
thank you Brandon you're the man good to
see you hope all is well
double dog picker let's go
thank you for the ten dollars it's very
nice of you appreciate it thanks
thank you thank you thank you good to
see you
my other half Thou Art yet to become me
that's right I do remember that
Thou Art yet to become me
blame a frenzy is chaos nature always
changing a meteor a flood Etc
yeah but you need that right to create
like create change and
somewhat balance in the world you know
can't have everything be good all the
time
it's not how it works
yeah how do they have children I mean
all right exactly wow
I think eldering is all about America
hating Ronaldo so much she made her fall
in love with her just to leave her salty
in the end
I had that theory about four or five
months ago
it's possible
like I made a a video on that and that's
pretty much what it is that's like one
of my first lore videos
but I'm not
entirely sure on that
so here's here's a question that I think
like answer yes or no to so we can get
back on like at least some type of track
here
do you guys think that radagon himself
radagon
is attacking us in the urge tree of his
own will or do you think it's the
greater will
so I guess is do you think it's radagon
or the greater will attacking us because
I think it's the greater will using him
as a puppet to attack us
I think it's yeah I definitely think
it's the greater will
why do you think it's radagon attacking
us
like we we are technically there
to mend the Eldon ring which is what he
wanted to do why would he stop us from
doing that
it would make sense if he attacked us
uh
if we were like going there to be the
flame of frenzy or we had the the three
fingers flame of frenzy within us
but no matter what we do when we go in
there he attacks us
because the greater whale uses his body
only after radagon fails
they they use his body
do they use his body to become the Elden
Beast I don't see it that way
it becomes a totally different thing
besides radagon
I don't see it that way
his sword is radagon's body
is it
his body becomes the elderly sword
so that's
okay
but
so why would radagon attack us
it's in the sword description what is
that sword called
I hope I didn't just open Photoshop
because that's gonna break this computer
right now
what was it called sacred
sacred Sword Sacred Relic sword
sword wrought with the remains of a god
who should have lived in a life eternal
thoughts on what the weapon pretends are
many and varied some consider the mark
of a great sin others of great
Devastation some think at the end of an
age While others the beginning
do you read this as radagon
look at the hilt
I don't know what a hilt is
you mean the sword
the handle
Tim and a t-post
oh okay
so you okay so
he they use his body to make the sword
I don't think that instantly
like makes so stage one
is
radagon's will
because I don't think it makes any sense
for radagon to attack us
I also don't think it makes any sense
for Melania to attack us but
there it is he still attacks us
which sometimes like man can if I if I
know where Michela is can I [ __ ] tell
her that would be so interesting
hmm But then
is the same body
so like when we end the game
and we can go up to America's husk and
mend the Elden ring right
is was that radagon's body changing back
after we killed the Eldon Beast or was
that just another thing
I think radagon attacks us the greater
will doesn't actually want change
radagon is a hardcore fundamentalist
believer the greater will and just
serves it
that does make sense
yeah do you guys think Melania attacks
us because she thinks that Nikola is
still in the tree and she's just
protecting the tree
actually makes no sense for her to just
randomly attack us
does America create radagon as an avatar
to have a vessel that holds her loyalty
to the greater will with radagon being a
follower
she can Rebel
no I know he's a fundamentalist that's
yeah that makes sense
it does look like she caresses the tree
like he's there
it's true lore randomizer once the Elder
ring was shattered the eldenbeast was
vulnerable
that's why he blocked the door right
radagon was trying to fix it calling
back Godfrey to gather the runes hence
Gideon
a god-free Watty
hello hello
the greater will doesn't care what order
there is as long as there is one radagon
cares about the more gold the golden
order specifically and wants to keep it
from changing
that makes sense I think America wants
to change everything and radagon does
not that's fine that that makes sense to
me
so I guess because Us ending anything
changes the golden order
no matter what he wants to stop us
I just wish I knew if he was a puppet or
not there man because in my opinion they
look dead
both both America and radagon look dead
and they're just bodies being flung
around by the greater will
well who knows like what dictates a god
being dead right or a vessel of a god
radagon was America's
loyalties incarnate
she could resist the greater will if she
poured that loyalty into radagon she
could potentially yeah
and then that's like another
like her hiding that truth from the
greater will right like she could go to
the greater will and say hey
uh I need I need a radagon to
fight my battles when instead she's
pouring all of that loyalty into him so
that she can Rebel is that what you're
saying
probably mini tarnish tried to get
melania's rune
yeah that's another theory man like
here's here's the other thing I have
trouble with
with what you just said
Jake another Jake hello
um
in the opening cut scene
the narrator says all of these tarnished
right it says Gideon dung eater FIA Etc
right Godfrey
and then he says and one other
this we're the only other
of those no renowned tarnished in this
world right
so are you saying like maybe Godfrey
tried to get melania's great room or or
Gideon or D or
you know whoever there could be lots of
others that we just haven't met yet
but we're the one other
is chat horny yet no chat doesn't get
horny right now
that's exactly what you're saying
handgun okay
gotcha
so she needed to manifest
an excuse
just like with her giving away her great
runes right
so like we all of the great runes were
in the Elden ring and she needed to find
a way to break the Elden ring she needed
a way to shatter it right
but with all it seems like I don't know
this is just a theory all of the runes
together she couldn't shatter it so
instead she tells the greater will I'm
going to give my children
their own great runes so that they can
spread our influence further
the greater will agrees lets her take
out the great rooms to give to her
children it makes it weaker and then she
shatters it
that's like another
Ploy for her
and then like after her wasn't she
I still don't know if this is like
entirely true
with the um
with the fire Giants and she was cursed
right which made her hair red
and then that's how radagon came to be
that's why he has red hair
is she had to manifest that curse off of
her to create radagon
she wants one of the tarnish to control
the Elden ring not gods and demigods
then couldn't Godfrey just do it
I mean was that just like a battle at
the end for us
like hey who's gonna do it it's gonna be
one of us
and then we battle it out and we win
I mean that's why Godfrey's Eric to seek
audience once more with Queen America
some Regency thought the tarnish being
around the shattering would be bad
I mean the theory on that would be that
this tarnish would be used as sacrifices
to make the golden order stronger but
they were gone they couldn't be used as
sacrifices
she divested thy Grace from each of them
which I said in a recent video it was to
protect them not just like banish them
so that the golden order couldn't just
take them and use them
it's kind of adding up a bit it just
turns into a theory that you know makes
sense but like there's so many things
that could make make it not make sense
and another thing makes sense
this is hard
hmm
no in-game descriptions for or against
it right
as always exactly
yeah I hope DLC answers a lot of these
questions man it's just like you know
how much more how much more do I want to
theorize
because I was talking about this earlier
in the Stream the reason I haven't been
making lore videos is because there's
been a a major
increase in people who don't want to
hear theories
they want facts they want the they want
the Smoketown vazi video stuff which is
like
technically things we already know but
are it's nice to have a cohesive videos
that they make so that we can like
understand what we're being shown which
is great
um if you haven't noticed with my videos
I like to go out there with some crazy
theories that I think are fun there has
just been a major increase in people who
just [ __ ] hate those Theory videos
they hate them they they don't want that
[ __ ] they want
hard facts you know
which has made me like uh sorry okay oh
okay you really don't like that it's
like 50 of people love it and 50 percent
of people just hate it like they get
actually angry that I even make a video
about it
like if I made a video on what we're
talking about right now 50 of people
would just like completely dismiss it
and call me like a [ __ ] scammer or
not a scammer but like a
I don't know
what is it what would the word be
spreading false information
misinformation Andy I I don't know like
that's I've seen so many comments like
that it just makes me not want to make
videos
vati used to do Theory crafty not to be
negative but from software being
mainstream brought in a lot of casuals
people want the story not the historians
and tatters right right
there are people that love Bulls I've
just like
I think people who comment
are
more bound to be negative than the
people who actually really like the
video but don't say anything does that
make sense
so like people who enjoy those Theory
videos don't make comments they watch it
enjoy it and like the video
whereas like I'll have a video that'll
have 98 like ratio like most people who
watch it love it and then I'll go in the
comments and it's just a bunch of people
who absolutely hate it and it it really
turns me off of making the videos
because
obviously the best way to interact with
the video is to comment right
or for me to get a grasp
it's just so weird
yeah I think I I probably just need to
post and not read comments
you know what I'm saying
I don't know it's it this is what I'm
saying right now is the reason I haven't
made a lore video in like a month
I just haven't I haven't wanted to
same thing hit The One Piece Community
to pull a parallel Theory crafting had
ups and downs in the community I gotcha
I gotcha
unless you present the lore video in a
more thematic fashion and the disabled
comments no I don't wanna I don't ever
want to disable comments like people can
say what they want that's fine it just
like
as a Creator it's really hard to just
like see people bash the [ __ ] out of you
in the comments like
people I've just noticed in the last
like month or two people are a little
bit more harsh than they were
a couple months ago
but they they will just hate a theory of
any kind
xylostorm claimed the entire thing was
an analogy for mushrooms
I love that theory
everyone hated it though like most
people did you know what I'm saying that
was such a good theory
which uh I think he made a great case
for
do I think it's true probably not but
that's okay I still enjoyed it
but he doesn't really make lore videos
now either and it's probably has to do
with that
he does uh like news updates and stuff
which we need
oh it doesn't I I think it's fine to
reach man like that's where we're at
you know
I think it's fine to reach on theories
but you can't nobody's gonna be like
which he didn't do you're not gonna be
like uh
you know that that squid out in the
distance over there guys that's mikola
that's my theory and then
provide no evidence like he didn't do
that I think he provided a lot of
evidence and
well I still think it's not true it's
it's okay
bit of a reach
whoops that was me sorry
let's add bit of a reach but I think
it's fun
oh another thing we got to talk about I
haven't even talked about this yet
um
the
great path ahead
I have resumed work on that
and it's gonna take me [ __ ] forever
to say the least
uh
I I'm getting a little bit perfectionist
on this thing
with uh
working on a cinematic way to tell the
lore
is very hard
um I'm voice acting my own character
which every time I replay that makes me
cringe because I hate my own voice
so that's that's tough but I kind of got
to deal with it
so yeah
but I'll try and get that I'll see you
guys as soon as I can it's it just takes
a lot of time
you can't keep getting away with this
okay Johnny
game is seven months old people gotta
Branch out melano's glomide Queen is
boring-ish at this point yeah I agree
I agree
exactly
yeah I I definitely want to make sure
it's good before I post it
because it's taking a lot of work
but I think once it's done you guys are
really gonna like it
it's just a different way to
engage with the lore
um without having to like read item
descriptions and
a narrator telling you exactly what
things mean things like that
anyway
hmm no I'm enjoying the ride man I just
uh I've just been streaming more
and it honestly it's been I've been
having more fun streaming than making
videos lately
so that's what I'm doing
like I'm gonna do what's fun
obviously
so
we cutting the stream here I think so
I think we got I think we got a lot
going on here
but I guess I'll I'll keep going
this was gonna be my last one
I think smoketown's death Birds is
pretty on point I think your discovery
about the twin Birds on the wall and
ferm as well ties into it pretty well
uh I'll have to watch that and see
because I I thought that was pretty cool
fine that we had the other day I'll take
a look at that man
we'll be back tomorrow with more
randomizer same time tomorrow boys
same time tomorrow
um I'm gonna go get some dinner I'm
gonna hang out with the fam I'm gonna
work on the video some more and then
we'll be back tomorrow sound good
you guys convinced me to keep going I'll
change the title
or in steenberg
he needs like a brother he'll be Oren
steenberg
hey appreciate you guys thanks for
hanging out today thanks for all the new
members we got a ton of new members
today that's awesome I'll try and make
those emotes that we came up with
earlier
uh path to somber 3 tomorrow guys
but thank you all thanks for the super
chats members subscribers we're getting
close to 100K every day we get a little
bit closer every day man so
thank you all very much we'll be back
tomorrow
um
maybe you'll see some uh lore videos too
I think I got some ideas so hey
have a great night everybody have a
great morning sleep well whatever time
it is for you and we'll see you tomorrow
bye guys